welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now proudly present for
them as a new sponsor Lending Tree do
you know that depending on where you get
your mortgage you could save $20,000 or
more but 80% of people only get one
mortgage offer and if you just go to
your bank chances are you're getting
ripped off Lending Tree does not want
that to happen
alright rates always go up and down but
regardless of what's happening with
rates you could always get the right
offer for you with Lending Tree calm are
you sure you have the best deal find out
how much you could save today at Lending
Tree calm / Church that's Lending Tree
calm / Church Lending Tree LLC and MLS
number one one three six terms and
conditions apply also let me ask you a
question
looking good doesn't need to cost you a
fortune
at 5-4 club is revolutionising the way
men shop right you don't have to walk
around looking like a model the time not
with the 5'4 club because you get $120
with the clothes for $60 a month but it
go to for Fight Club right now and then
to promo code Joey and they'll give you
50% off your first month's package plus
a free pair of sunglasses you'll be
looking like a doctor again that's 50%
off your first package at the 5'4 Club
spelled five-0 you are club.com
promo code Joey also added calm give me
some lovely
kick that meal [ __ ] it's a
beautiful day to be alive Monday July 10
the Church of what's happening now Eddie
if Lisa at are you [ __ ] kidding me
you could jump
the window at any time right now if
you're in your car open up that door and
just jump out of the car cause they
ain't gonna get no better than this
[ __ ]
here we go don't leave here we go kick
that mule [ __ ] hit it pull em
pum pum pum pum pum Oh
the Churchill what's happened now
[ __ ] headed Lee
Beliveau boo are you [ __ ] kidding me
or what bus stop that [ __ ] number
here we go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's
happening you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey at least I got my main man Eddie
IFFT is on the show this evening how are
you my friend great thanks for having me
thanks for having yon last night few
people want to ask listen last night
podcast was [ __ ] hilarious
you know listen when people tell you
don't touch the edibles don't touch the
edibles all right it's like when you go
to the zoo they told [ __ ] with the line
you should put his dead don't [ __ ] with
the edibles unless you have good
intentions Pauly Shore found that out
the hard way last night he called this
morning said he puked the other pull
over 18 times Oh [ __ ] nightmare he
puked on his sandals with him I was so
scared when it came in here nah it's
like a vapor in here I read uh rent you
know Twitter you don't see anybody's
tweets anymore you got so many people
all of a sudden I see a tweet from you
that says r.i.p Pauly Shore and I went
oh [ __ ] like Pauly Shore died like and
so I start like I go over to the news to
see what they're gonna be singing in the
news and I'm like oh Pauly's dead and
I'm like holy [ __ ] and then I look at
other comedians I'm like they hasn't
even gotten to the news yet like like
Joey he's got the inside track and Polly
died so then I started thinking I'm like
I felt really bad because Polly and I
weren't close we didn't get along and
I'm talking about him like he's dead and
up we didn't get along and we got in
this like argument like years ago and I
remember we got in the arguments it's
like 15 years ago he goes you're never
gonna play my mom's comedy club ever
ever ever I swear to God I headlined for
the first time the Comedy Store in San
Diego this week it was my first time
working there and I'm thinking I killed
Paul found that yeah yeah and he was
just like [ __ ] I'm going to Joey Diaz
isn't duh and I really thought he died
and I said to my wife I'm like I think
Pauly Shore died and uh
and it was like and then I just looked
everywhere else and then I saw all your
comments and your bangs like oh don't
eat the Black Stars oh my god
oh boy Felicia called this morning
Michael's asking me what happened she
was laughing how many know she thought
he died too
yeah that she read it and she saw some
of the comments like you and she knew
what it meant when the red stars got him
you know the [ __ ] stars red stars her
black ones last night he had a blue one
those red ones those two blood ones
we're out of them until next week
thank God the Bible ones yeah the purple
I listened to you once and it was like
an education I got on unedible because
I'm not good with them at all like I've
had a really really bad time it started
out good and I wish it had stayed that
way because I really enjoyed it the
first time I did it second time loved it
third time though maybe the worst 24
hours of my life yeah it's good taking a
weird direction
I'm a town mayor get back on you get
back on the meal yeah I got as a kid
like with alcohol I would be hugging the
ball puking think it was never gonna end
you key but I could get back on the meal
then the next day but with weed you [ __ ]
with my head I thought I went crazy and
I thought I wasn't coming back I got a
nice Oh like the exercise thing and she
saw her heart well it only goes when you
work out oh that would make it get even
worse she [ __ ] didn't do like a year
either she's like that that's terrible
get her head she wants it gets in your
head yeah it happens to me once it gets
in your head that's the problem that's
what was happening like that's why yeah
yesterday I went to the store and I got
a rice krispies treat I almost made it I
gotta go
I take one of those out of bullying or
jujitsu it's not the same it is the
situation somebody gets on top of yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy
you don't listen oh yeah you get
paranoid it's rich it's really funny
about what I'm gonna tell you guys and
they've told me a thousand times you
know listen I had a college I don't
[ __ ] know I don't want I got left
back in the seventh grade on that but
anything I do know is because I did it
and did it over you know I guess what
was it yeah yes I am - wheat store which
one of my microd that acid there was an
older black woman there I was from
Jersey for me sorry and she was sort of
Micra that acid you know and I laugh
because people send me clips I'm Joe
Rogan and Thompson go over another
comics saying how high my town and says
they think you're born with that I feel
I freaked out the reason why my limits
his eyes cuz I've been a dumpster on my
life of drugs I'm ashamed to admit that
drug dumpster no no no no the truth
which is what you get for [ __ ] being
an [ __ ] people laugh I feel well you
an [ __ ] people laugh at you and when
you're admit you're an [ __ ] you have
to take the laughter forbidding your
[ __ ] ass up I'm a garbage dumpster you
know and I feel bad for leave but I'm
trying to when Lee sees edibles I'm not
trying to [ __ ] with Lee well a little
bit like I'm presenting listen man just
might kiss is about one thing not
believing I know Joey I I want the
listeners never to believe what they're
telling you it's like when we tell him
we go to the airport's
I don't give a [ __ ] when I got a coach
ticket like one of the first line thing
first-class life ticket
that's just a way of it and by the way
he does this with with me or without yet
but he does this at 5 a.m. as high as he
is right now right now I get stoned to
the gills like he's gonna pray I tell
people this podcast is about believing
and not believing the ocean I look at
people since I was a kid I've listened
to people I said this guy's just gonna
[ __ ] like when I was a kid my mom
had a bar so there'd be drugs all around
and I'd see people stolen coke so for
years I'd have to go out and listen to
people
about cocaine and I never raised my hand
I never said like they go what do you
know I don't know no real life I'd see
people snort and stuff but as I got
older you know I smoked weed then I
snorted that [ __ ] THC crystal which
was angel dust I did acid for [ __ ] 18
months I was doing it five days a week
Wow you know I was taking two or three
hits a night smoking it you know we
didn't do much the acid we just put it
in the bowl
and it does it works yeah like a little
[ __ ] microdot put it in the bowl this
kid Vinny got you talking sex ah well
yesterday I bumped into three in the
morning bought three hits and he put one
in a pipe and what are you doing
oh you I didn't know you could do that
who'd do that there were just chemicals
you know your lungs are shot God knows
what goes into your lung how's mini
today is he okay he's blinking from time
there's no I don't know I haven't seen
him he's a big time but it's just funny
how like I'd done everything so I can't
I don't believe people and they go wow
your hands you don't unless I'm like
Keith Richards jr. yeah I think that too
I read about some people but there are
those people that one time and then they
don't you know like lose it I just think
that there are people like when I was
younger I could drink anything
everything I never really got into the
drug thing other than smoking a little
weed but I just couldn't do it and I
loved alcohol I loved it I wanted to get
drunk every day but I wanted events I
liked events you know like what are we
gonna do today let's go if I hike in the
woods will bring about all Jack Daniels
let's go to a baseball game
we'll buy beers and then we'll drink
more beers and we'll do shots you know
it was always like more and more and
more I don't know why I stayed away from
the drugs how old were you when you
started drinking 15 are you from
Pittsburgh
yeah that's you got address the culture
yeah maybe that's what it was
how much is Pittsburgh change so much in
the last like five years of break yard
yes and no yes and no me it's weird
I like I'm not a real Pittsburgher I
grew up in the suburbs okay and they
look at me like you [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
you know like they didn't I'm not
accepted in Pitt do I love Pittsburgh
yes do I have Pittsburgh eating me like
my dad
from Bloomfield my mom grew up in
squirrel-like my whole family's involved
in sports and Pittsburgh Pittsburgh
sports but my dad was insurance salesman
made some money moved out to the suburbs
not a lot of money but like enough that
two cars in a house you know kind of
thing like and you know if you're not a
steel worker and you're not like from
the mill and that they just even the
girls want nothing to do with you they
look at the kids from the suburbs like
and Pittsburgh has hot hot like like
lower middle-class skanky girls like
beautiful beautiful like the kind you go
I'm gonna get some money someday and I'm
gonna come so pull her out of here
because she's prettier than any girl out
of any [ __ ] country club anywhere and
you just pop this chicken and they'll
all be like where the [ __ ] did you find
her and you just dress her butt and
they're skanky but they want nothing to
do with any guy that doesn't you know
working like blue-collar
[ __ ] you know guy and so you know I'd
go out when I was in my 20s I go to like
the nightclub night clubs and think I
couldn't [ __ ] cook
I couldn't go up against those dudes you
know they're all [ __ ] jacked and and
you know they got tickets in the end
zone to the Steeler games it was it was
uh it's like two different it's kind of
like other city I see is like that it's
just somewhere that's just like that is
it everyone on the East Coast that is
it's a certain mentality and it's a
blue-collar mentality and sometimes I
said you're gonna go why I would like to
quit commie
excuse me that list do five years at
lifestyle like this times I'm out of my
mind of the blue-collar lifestyle you
know I I think of my brother-in-law my
brother-in-law works 70 hours a week
normal shifts you know to support two
kids
yeah house you know he works [ __ ]
constantly and I can't I always whenever
I feel down on comedy you're down on
what's going on I think him yeah I think
of the decision I made you know to
pursue this and stick with it
and now my family is eating you know
yeah and years we ate but we ate weird
and now we're eating you know and downs
and it's based on belief but it's so
weird that this times I love thinking I
love goodnight at night and thinking
about my life what could have happened
what could have been what the difference
is and I'm kind of mad at myself why a
little bit but not really I'm mad at
myself for leaving at times like I see
my buddies now like on Facebook this 12
of them in a [ __ ] golf tournament why
play golf
I wouldn't [ __ ] play golf yeah he
[ __ ] paid so boy you know that's the
community I came from here you're a
comic but I didn't see comedians in my
weekly yeah it was a different type of
friendship don't suburb friendship yeah
I know yeah I agree with you that's so
20% of me I'm like Jesus Christ right
now I could have been living in North
Bergen I could have been maybe making 75
grand a year you know
you take one vacations in Miami yeah
take one big vacation days eat some crab
legs yeah I love Miami's just a little
vacation but they see they sees the big
one you get the white shoes out your tip
a little extra you know that's your
whole year like you save up 11 I was
watching The Honeymooners last night and
they were part of the raccoons and they
go to a raccoon convention once a year
I'm jealous of those people
I'm jealous oh I'm jealous them for sure
there's a different there's a there's an
attraction to that lifestyle that at
times I go what the [ __ ] that I do look
at these people I talk to people with no
souls yeah we'll just go from train to
train the train until they find the red
[ __ ] that's right then when that train
crashes they find those 28 year old and
they were angle 10 of those guys then
they start all over again and they do
that three times in their lifetime and
put on by the agents and manage yeah
that old [ __ ] pain you know you could
be here for 30 years not selling ticking
be the funniest guy in the world sell
three tickets and awesome they are what
I know then jumping out of the woodwork
so I'm not come comedy clubs anymore
they're popular cannot be the club I
don't I don't you know I miss all those
little things like this times I said
think oh Jesus Christ you know I never
want to know my high school reunion you
know leaves has been talking lately
about going to his 10-year reunion Sox
don't go is he in here go ticket 700
[ __ ] dollars what no back in Boston
yes oh brother plane ticket it's not
worth it 600 bucks the Boston
Thanksgiving weekend kills it two birds
with one stone he sees his mom oh thanks
to her mom do it for Mom
listen my mom's let me tell you what I
thought about Italy so I gotta tell you
something if you go there and look
around you might just be depressed yeah
I take the chance
li let me tell you I went to my high
school reunion and I was really excited
and it was like my 20th or something and
I was so excited I was like this is
[ __ ] amazing I'm gonna see ya and I'm
still keep in touch with a lot of my
friends so we were all talking about we
were all looking forward to it the night
before our high school reunion
my one friend had a party at her house
and it was just like high school people
were drinking beer bongs people were
doing keg stands it just got [ __ ]
like it was just like high school and
we're having the best time we were all
[ __ ] making fun of each other like we
did you know giving Petrie my wedgie or
whatever it was and we had the best time
and then we're like all right tomorrow
is the big night and we went to this
pool and we all swam the next day and
had a barbecue we were all together all
my friends and then we went to the
reunion where the whole school comes and
it sucked because I was around a bunch
of people that I didn't want to be
around and all my friends that I was
with the Dave of the day of and the
night before I was like hey we should
get out of here and go back to like
so-and-so's house you know we'll party
and it was like high school again you're
in your little clique you got your group
of friends their group everybody went
off in their group of friends realized I
never liked you in high school that's
why I moved out of this life here I got
my friends and I so I said all my
friends why do we even [ __ ] go to
that thing and pay you we should have
just got had a party and hung out yeah
you know what that I have like one
really good friend through high school
they call him and go see you yeah I
should go now for Thanksgiving cuz that
like I don't want to be a bummer
and when I say this when I say bully I
don't want him it's not like the kids
now or killing themselves and like it
wasn't like that but I just never really
felt like I fit in I don't know like I
always I always wanted to go to those
parties and I don't know like I was
chubby so like people who like make
people laugh but it wasn't I never
really felt like but then I'm an idiot
like I would sit at home some weekends
be like no one's called me to hang out
and I wouldn't call anyone to hang out
someone maybe I just called someone
stupid but like part of me thinking of
going back is like why like I don't keep
in touch with any of them
yeah and they weren't it wasn't like we
were best friends 10 years ago so maybe
I yeah maybe I should just call that one
guy and Billy a little hang out for a
weekend that's my philosophy in this
business much better so many clicks and
people won't let you in I just got like
this go where you're wanted go away from
where you're not wanted
like right yeah people that don't like
you're just never gonna help you or do
anything with you or create anything but
so just work with the people to do it's
funny how when I go to Pittsburgh I make
it yeah I like it I like the people I
nice food good Chinese wine livery what
the man I used to work the [ __ ] funny
bones yeah yeah oh the the point
brothers yeah hey Alec brothers they
finally closed up when they're done I
wasn't I was right there when it was
happening I was involved in it it was
terrible like I was one of the last
locals to pull the plug on them and go
over to the improv and he held it
against me and I they they had me come
up his first club I ever worked
open-mike first club I ever stepped in
1996 and Jeff and Keith Schneider and I
like the guys and but he just he was mad
when I went over the improv but they
just you know he wouldn't ever up my
money and I felt bad I felt bad yeah I
like that Club look I like the improv I
work for a lot of them but that funny
bone was kind of cool it was around
forever and it was really cool the first
weekend that worked up there was really
cool no one back did you work then which
room did you work the balcony one was it
by the incline 2005 oh no then you were
at the in 2006 and like 2008 that's a
big rim then okay so 2005 I went that's
the longest yard and it was cool then a
year later he called me again and I want
this time I took a red-eye suck dick
yeah that's a dick a red-eye connection
to Pittsburgh oh that's all there was
that oh and you were living out here
yeah holy [ __ ] oh it sucked dick and I
took a [ __ ] edible from from [ __ ]
uh the cush Mart I used to have a 250
milligrams brownie you can you can you
please keep me up on cuz I don't get the
milligrams a million to 250 at that
talent in 2008 that was [ __ ] dangerous
like do and now it's nothing how many
how many milligrams would you get
smoking one joint petals oh I don't know
I know that a guy like you Vee ten
milligrams you're gonna feel really and
then you'll work yourself up through
time you know yeah you're a thin guy
yeah yeah yeah that's why they only sell
ten milligram doses at these places okay
because that's where you can handle ten
how many how many milligrams do you
think you've had before we started the
show tonight
yeah I got a know I have you saw me I
put there was one ball that was four of
them that tasted like ass blue it looked
like the end of them well I don't know
what I could do Lee I was like caught
like this like [ __ ] go for the
swallow and they had to be four or five
in that chunk i blew like threes chunks
of threes a two of those things it's not
that way close to 2,000 years we're
close Wow but now forever and I could do
10 you do 10 now at that time there ate
the whole brownie like a [ __ ] a vault
in my leg one step there's sometimes
edibles backfire if I've been on 200
flights
they've backfired four times oh that's
Miami once Pittsburgh once that's where
I had a bad experience on Chicago one
time on the way back from Midway on a
plane on Hannibal yeah 200 flights three
three experiences that I remember that
was a little consequence
this last time I put a song on this is
the weirdest anxiety attack I ever got
this was maybe four weeks ago oh this
just happened this is this is the last
one that just happened that wasn't a bad
one and I handled it beautifully I
handled it beautifully the one freaked
out was the sweaty one on the Ordway
when I weighed about 380 I hate the
whole pack of us the [ __ ] stickers
and on the way back it's when Southwest
had the chairs that faced each other
from across my three grandmothers I'm
sweating profusely and finally just take
off quick that was the first time we
Gabriel and Marty Moreno there was
another another time on the way to Miami
on a red-eye freaked that time I [ __ ]
got off the plane I went to get the ride
I went to pull my pants up two inches of
my pants with dry stance what was that
the cinnamon candy one this that's when
I ate the edibles and they had a whole
pack of cinnamon certs and thus enemy
must must ignited something there was
this gay guy next really lovely toggles
man with a blank and I'm sitting there
four in the morning no shirt on with the
blanket up to here I would be taking
pictures and if you upgrade me out of
first-class taking I'm taking my [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] shirt when I'm playing
so two times I took my shirt off I was
three times I freaked out the time with
the tits the time in that one and the
time the Pittsburgh was the red-eye the
last two hours of that flight my leg
wouldn't stop tapping about 30 minutes I
was ready to ring the bell you gotta get
me off this flight my mic won't stop
tapping III didn't have the balls to
ring the battle finally we land and I
walk with a limp like my leg was dead
something happened with the [ __ ]
edible but then about four weeks ago I
took a plane with some body I take the
plane which I took the plane with some
body we sat upon on Southwest
and I told my wife to download some
music from me I gave her a list I went
through a bunch albums I hadn't heard
and there was one particular out that I
used to listen to every night with a
friend of mine would be driving around
snorted and there was 1983 and we
listened to he was heartbroken over a
[ __ ] I was heartbroken over a [ __ ] I
knew I was leaving New Jersey I was just
waiting to rob the right person yes all
I was waiting on was the right drug
choice the right drug dealer and I got a
hold of a loan shark he [ __ ] served
the purpose I got him for a couple grand
I got this other guy for a couple grand
and we used to listen to a song and that
dad got on Southwest as soon as I sat
down the amiable started hitting me and
I'm like let me put my earphones on I
put the [ __ ] here phones on and put
this album on and I'm just listening for
the sound from 1983 free phone like I
just put it on and wherever it song
I forgot what songs were around it I
forgot everything I liked the fifth song
it was a song that just took me Eddie
IFFT it just took my anxiety to a
different level like I must have had
something at stake with this song like
something it triggered something
it [ __ ] triggered me on this plane so
much I had to take the earphones and
throw them off me and I looked for the
[ __ ] stewardess I was breathing heavy
I asked her for a [ __ ] water and I
pop the [ __ ] xanax the xanax help
really not really those things don't do
damn me those 2.5 I got any like six of
them
I got on a plane once I did a gig one
night and it was in Australia so my
first trip ever have I go to Australia a
lot and I think my first time I ever
went was like around like 2005 or
something maybe 2000 yeah 2005 I went
ever do a show and I went to the small
town called Adelaide and they said the
first night I went it was awesome the
crowd was great and everybody was
laughing it was really fun and I partied
with everyone and then they said you're
here for three nights when I went to
another gig the next night and I look
around and the audience is all the same
people that was at the first show and I
go this is kind of weird you know
there's the whole all the same people I
partied with them all last night they go
yeah yes I was like I got another hour
in me
you know I can do to it so I just did an
hour I was like okay
and they were big in the weed Natalie
they loved their weed and they're proud
of their we I go the third night same
[ __ ] people and I don't have more
than two hours material at that time I'd
like a mix and I go [ __ ] what am I gonna
do and I'm watching all the comics the
openers go up and I'm like I'm not a
[ __ ] these are all the same people I
can't do my same act it's weird
so this girl had had a had she makes pot
brownies her name's Fred she wouldn't
care if I told her name she she's famous
from him she gets everybody sick on the
meet too much they get sick if you ever
go to add a little hook you up with Fred
or London she lived him both but she
makes these pot cookies he's pot brownie
forget if it was a cookie so we're
sitting in the audience and I look at
her and I go give me the cookie and she
goes no [ __ ] way the Booker will kill
me I'll be fine just give me the cookie
cause home hoping is he'll get me so hot
just go I'll go off and I'll have a
whole new bunch material so I eat the
cookie and I start [ __ ] laughing like
I've never laughed and his comics are on
stage and they're shushing me because
I'm laughing so hard I'm like this is
hilarious this is the and I've got a
friend down then it's got him big out
when he laughs you laugh
got that laughs you know that laughs
that just no one has it he's real big
dude like fat dude and he has a
high-pitched laugh and when he goes he's
contagious so so I'm losing it and then
I went onstage and I did like three
hours and I got offstage and I got the
show and they're like that's good I'm
like how long that do them they're like
yeah it was good I did I do it was all
kind of original she they go to that
they go yeah you talked about them like
some razor like a Mach 3 turbo or
something they go talked about it for
like an hour yeah they go there you go
we don't even have that race you know
it's funny whenever I take edibles and
go on stage on the road where it matters
it's like me go on stage years ago it's
a 50/50 shot but one thing always stays
clear your relaxation levels really good
until the panic until well no no no no
that's just weird saying that you just
get it with it you feel the edible
creeping on it's when you do acid really
drunk like that not like coke coke it
you run away age hit you right away it's
like when you do ecstasy or do some type
of ass and you're waiting for it to hate
you when it hits you for those first two
minutes you know you're there and that's
what happens to me sometimes on stage
when the stage when you hit the stage it
does something completely different that
he of them because the lights hit you
and you have eyeballs looking at you so
that fear mixes of the adrenaline and
either could either go one way that he
going a different direction I've got on
stage on mushrooms
one time Oh God and that was pretty good
cocaine that don't work for nobody even
really even the after effect of cocaine
because it throws your timing off throw
your timing off it takes your soul away
so you can't put your material into your
heart you
you're a mannequin man with a tape
recorder okay and you feel it on stage
but I think and I don't know I don't
have any experience with it but I would
think what I've heard is it gives you
this fake confidence and sometimes I
feel like my my issue on stage is like
sometimes I'm fully confident and then
other times I I analyzed the audience
too much like Seoul Korea and I'll go
there you know she's an older woman and
this is didn't know you thank you yeah
and so I feel like with cocaine I would
get up there and just Vic I don't give a
[ __ ] what anyone thinks this is what I
find funny and I'm gonna do it right now
no really it was a really bad experience
I was net listen I'm not good at two
things I'm not good at talking when I'm
on cocaine and I'm not good with alcohol
if I have a drink I come out a fighter
hmm Oh an argue or one of those guys I'm
just not good like if I'm driving the
car and I have one beer and I spent two
hours are going to cop pulls me over how
lose it really yeah I don't know why
because I'm guilty yeah I know myself I
should not drink and drive
so my guilt that's why I don't do it
yeah I drank two beers a night in Vegas
this weekend that's it I told my wife
that's a good world record yeah I'm not
why I'm lying to you the one night I
drink a beer to have that's still a
world record for me anything a beer is a
world record for me the one that I left
this much at the at the card when we
were playing cards I put the beer down I
forgot it was warm that's the only
reason why I left three inches I'm not
I'm not proud of it but uh probably from
the age of 16
till maybe 30 to 33 I was a hardcore
drunk driver and I'm not proud of it at
all but I did it like I don't know why I
didn't think there was any chance of
failure
blackouts um you think no I never black
no I always felt fully under control to
the point of like and it's not true but
I felt better like like I was switched
on like I was like and no accidents no
anything thank God you know and I think
it's terrible because I could have
killed somebody but I do feel like it
had a different effect on me now now I
don't do it and I can
to it cuz I have two drinks and I want
to take a nap and when I'm driving home
sober I'm falling asleep so on alcohol
I'm like don't get me near a car I've
slept him I went out with the TEL one
night I ended up sleeping in the back of
my car in front of the improv they found
me in the morning like I all I wouldn't
drive this was like years ago before it
L quit and I would I
I just won't do it now I don't drunk
drive I just never ever it's good the
[ __ ] out of me yeah I'd see I saw the
effect of it kill somebody and then I
saw how [ __ ] up they got towards it I
got one time not that they were lenient
towards drunk driving but it was an
initial ya know just a [ __ ] ish it's
an issue you gotta write a boss for six
months yeah you gotta get special and
sure yeah yeah I'm gonna take classes
don't put a [ __ ] you wanted Jam don't
put the put you in jail you got to put a
phone in your car and breathe through it
just in case [ __ ] something happens I
mean it really really is like I wouldn't
wish on anybody she ever heard the jim
Florentine joke about it jim has a joke
about how the old days used to get
pulled over for shrinks in driving the
big cops would be like get in the back
will drive you on yeah and then they'd
be like can you pick up another six-pack
on the way home the cops be like all
right it was me Tatum in the [ __ ]
late seventies and eighties where where
there was a it started to become a well
I can await 70 79 80 there were an ads
yet but people were talking you know
three kids got drunk on the prom yeah
got killed
yeah so people started taught and I just
I saw an accident one night and then I
just
I just knew there was something about it
that didn't work for me I just didn't
work on me drunk driving and then I saw
the point what they laid on people but
it's not what I just saw the fines and
interest somebody
somebody told me California I think a
DUI is like gonna end up costing a 20
grand or something that's said and done
and I was like I don't want a [ __ ]
pit pony grand for anything oh no I
don't have weed in my karma pocket yeah
I thought we might go and don't smoke
weed in my car and I don't [ __ ] like
when I go to the store during the
weekend I don't [ __ ] do edibles like
I just drive down there yeah I won't
drink when I'm there well I'm down there
sometime top smoke enjoy yeah but
besides that by 6 o'clock I'm done for
that man I'd do this for the podcast
because Lee and I get high but no when
I'm driving at night no no no because I
can't lose my driving right yeah and it
[ __ ] you up yeah there's so many things
that people don't realize like you can't
leave the country some some countries
won't let you in if you have that on
your record or there's there's weird
kind of [ __ ] and I just like especially
when I'm in other countries
never-ever we gotten I went to the
Middle East to do shows we are doing
Dubai and we left the venue with beers
in our hands out to the van
we got a call the next day like don't
ever [ __ ] do that again
you were just drinking in public in the
Middle East like that will get you
thrown in prison
we were crazy they're like yeah and you
swore around women we had a woman like
guide that was taking us around and
apparently she like informed on us for
cursing
these guys put a put a jab on your head
and throw rocks at you we stick a couple
couple swear words and work we're going
to prison I'm gonna tell you something
guys I'm gonna thought I'd travel he
should have crossed borders
yeah it is terrifying it is less and
less do I want to do it this [ __ ] kid
from North Korea came back we thought it
yeah for that white kid and the Koreans
of 20 years at a time they sent the guy
over
nine three days they put like a time on
him the kid was definitely walked off
the wine he was walking half-dead yeah
any more water than come on yeah yeah
like a battery what are these do wrong
was he stealing some stuff yeah they
said oh you know you and I both know
that as kids we all did the hotel to get
15 years well you don't even I don't
even talk English you can't you're away
from your whole [ __ ] fail you know
why did why did he go there who the [ __ ]
cares you know these [ __ ] people cuz
they're BS to be international but it
has to be cool everybody has to see
something Murphy has to [ __ ]
everybody has to [ __ ] don't say you
know that's why and he went over and he
[ __ ] around at the wrong place and
they gave fifteen years and you know and
it's hard cuz you don't when you go to a
country they don't tell you [ __ ] no one
ever tell you about North Korea that's
like why even there was one of those
dudes I got invited there I got invited
my friend was running a marathon there
and they don't in North Korea and North
Korea they open it up yeah and they let
Americans coming in too and I went yeah
you're out of your [ __ ] mind there's
no way I was in India doing stand-up and
after I did my first show the comics all
came out you know you're so crazy you're
so daring I don't know not like nobody
thinks I'm that in America she they go
oh you said some stuff and I was like
what they're like we have an offense law
here if you offended anyone in the
audience they can go tell the police and
they arrest you and I was like I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of this country as soon
as possible like how do I end it do it
they said you don't know these things
and yeah you never like I uh I was in
one country and I was thinking about my
computer they open up people's computers
look I'm like oh my god
I think pornography is illegal here I
probably have porn all over my [ __ ]
laptop if they checked my cache and I'm
gonna go to prison like if they like you
just don't know what you can and can't
do Dubai I saw I was at a party people
were doing cocaine I heard you get 17
years in prison for just having it in
your system not even having it on you
and I just said to three other comedians
like oh we got to get the [ __ ] out of
here right now
like [ __ ] around no way I don't know
the [ __ ] rules
yeah it's scary alright I just don't I
don't get the whole I you know it's like
I don't have a passport and part of me
is depressed but the other part of me is
like I'm good with it
you know what I feel like I feel like
you used to go see things cuz you wanted
to experience him but now the world so
globe you can go on Google Images see
anything you wanted to see and then see
ten thousand pictures that people have
taken over their videos and it's like
okay like we're in India they're like
you want to go to the Taj Mahal like oh
yeah we should go see it they're like
it's like four hours away I'm like I'll
just check it out on Google Images you
know there's certain things you can't
pass up like there's certain things I
would love to [ __ ] see like that the
wall the underground thing in Israel
will you write the notes and put them in
the ward on the ground whatever the [ __ ]
it is I like to go to Cuba I like to go
to Ireland can't go to Cuba now they're
[ __ ] that up
no they're [ __ ] that up a few [ __ ]
places Australia my dear friends
Australia's a great place to [ __ ] go
down there got a dear friend he's do you
do great there they love you that
promise it's it that that's flight Oh
see those flights you gotta take time
you gotta take a stalk you got ten of
these [ __ ] things so you wake up and
they like you here you're here you need
a meal in three days good I ate a that
girl that gave me the pot cooking
Australia when I was going I was going
from Adelaide back to Sydney it's only
like a two-hour flight and she goes I go
hey I don't eat in half the night before
which was smart I said give me the other
half only the other half and she's like
well I go I think the plane flight will
be fun I just okay she goes it's
probably gonna hit you when you land
though it's only like a two-hour flight
it's not gonna digest I went I ate it in
Australia you only have to be at the
airport like a half hour before you get
on a flight they'd they're civil and
normal and human they got two doors on
the plane so you enter the front and
back half the time they don't keep you
like a caged rat
so I'm sitting on the plane I've got the
aisles wait I think I got the aisle seat
guys I got the aisle and oh no no I
window mother and son the aisle in the
middle the Sun is [ __ ] like really
[ __ ] and it oh but I'm walking down
the jet way from the from the you know
the airport down to my plane and she
told me it hit me when I land my legs
just started to feel like rubber bands
like I was just like oh my god it's
coming here it comes so I got my seat
and I thought I'm gonna sit down just
I'll just I'll get through this no
problem then I started feeling like like
I had to pee so bad and this kid sits
down with his mom and I look over at him
and I just don't handle it well I'm like
he's [ __ ]
and I'm sorry I don't mean to say
anything disparaging about people with
mental illness but it just got too much
it was too much for me when I was high
and I love Enya painting yourself in a
[ __ ] corner and more ways than one so
I couldn't get out
can't get the [ __ ] I couldn't get out of
the seat and his mother about halfway
through I was like I gotta go pee I
gotta go listen that seat gives me
inside yeah his mother started feeding
him she gave him a sandwich and I you
know they say that like some [ __ ]
people have like a sixth sense I swear
to god this kid knew I was high and he
knew that I needed to get out of that
seat and she gave him a sandwich to eat
and he didn't eat it bite by bite he was
picking crumbs off of it and like
putting them on his tongue and just like
looking at me just like he was because I
couldn't conjure up I couldn't ask him
to move but I needed to get out so badly
and I'm in my head I'm like as soon as
he finishes
Susy's finishes his sandwich just I
don't want to disrupt his meal I'll get
out I'll go to the bathroom and he was
just looking at me like and time Stood
Still and when the flight attendant said
this to me I remember I took I took you
know the safety card I wrapped it around
my head so I couldn't see him and I just
sat there like this and the flight
attendant came up and tapped me and said
are you okay I was like she says so so
hungry when I got off the plane I ran to
McDonald
I swear to god the girl the counter goes
are you okay
like I must look like yeah I was through
the whip yeah he was just [ __ ] it was
like he had special powers and he was
just he looked me right in the eyes and
was like I'm gonna destroy you
it's different on the plane okay it gets
you it gets you super high and like I he
but the one time we're not the one time
the first time he did it to me or he
gave it to me
I I was convinced that the stewardess
forgot to like come to my aisle for food
and I had was crazy hungry because of
course we take edibles at 4:00 in the
morning but we don't stop now we stop
for breakfast if it's open we stop for
breakfast now that the the burger the
egg burger but that morning nothing was
open I think we was like the first
flight out that morning nothing was open
to edibles go good with food cuz when
the third time my really bad time I was
eating these these cookies you gotta get
their biscuits their Australian biscuits
called a Tim Tams and it was my first
night ever happened it's a chocolate
biscuit with a it's like a biscuit with
a chocolate coating you bite off the
ends and if you're drinking coffee you
use it like a straw and the hot coffee
comes up it melts in your hand and you
gotta like smash it in your mouth and
it's the I'm telling you it's one of the
it's like the ninth wonder of the world
if you have it it's called a Tim Tam
slam when you do it with coffee and they
just start selling them in America it's
a it's heavenly so I'm doing this I'd
eaten half a pot cookie and I start
doing Tim Tams and I'm like I mean
you're supposed to have like two like
they're like coffee biscuit
I've eaten an entire package and the
girls told me that the sugar probably
like made the pot go quicker they're
like you activated your system that's
what happens with the certs so I walked
it I stood up I felt good sitting and I
looked at the girls and I knew a
turnaround and I just went make it stop
make it stop whatever has happened like
whatever is in this you gotta make it
stop right now and they're like we can't
and I was like how long is this gonna
last and they go forever good yeah and I
went tomorrow
tomorrow hmm yeah that's kind of what
happened it was until tomorrow
well they're weird man
well I'll tell you what I enjoy that
people eating them in contrast to heavy
stuff like I saw those the dad like came
out like three weeks ago on CNN CNN
[ __ ] put these numbers up CNN likes
drugs and they were talking about
[ __ ] how the states that have medical
marijuana there's less OPA what emerges
oh really good it like that emergency
room visit so who the [ __ ] knows you
gonna help me with some Toni better than
gonna sit there like move to law you
forgot it's Monday [ __ ]
see you had it all lined up thing I
never forget about Tony Bennett how dare
you
you
the last two okay fair enough a couple
minutes your nose do they taste good
like [ __ ] heaven like those tam-tam
they're really good
did you see how it's stuck to the
computer it sticks like spider-man's
foot that's when you know you're in for
a long [ __ ] night there's some shout
out to you real quick what do they taste
like these are actually a really good
flavor these are the sour blue ones
these are good yeah these are like a
gummy bear condoms yeah yeah
cracker CJ 2501 raisin Leslie cap oh no
for three Jeep thanks for coming to
Vegas [ __ ] Brad Ebert Brian Romero
jrv and Krista Finnegan you sexy [ __ ]
anyway sorry about that
no it's nice reason I see you do that to
your fans to let these [ __ ]
know that I fans they're family at this
boy we're doing this [ __ ] [ __ ] for so
long I feel like the same thing like
yeah I've had fans
I shouldn't come fail I used to come
[ __ ] heads when I was talking [ __ ] and
now it's the Bingle show it's Bingle
berries they've done so much for you and
so many guys have like really helped out
that they're now my buddies like they
come over to my house and I know some
people think that's weird but it's like
we all by talking on this format you
find people that are totally into what
you're into think like you talk to it's
like that's dating I never got the date
in the [ __ ] computer world I would
have liked to because I think it's great
you cut through all the [ __ ] well
these guys we know we got [ __ ] I had a
guy over at my house today working on
the bus with me
I've guys like I go I've got guys in
towns now you know Bob Lingus yeah we
got all those it's great I'm going that
town that I used to never know anyone
and all of a sudden I got like a couple
buddies you call they picked Lee up they
take him out the Mexican food you know
it's uh wait about it we had a friend
come in from Australia yeah this past
weekend that's awesome when I give a
shot I came with his sisters he came to
both shows he hooked up with Anna he had
some edibles where were you this weekend
I was at the South Pointe casino had a
great [ __ ] time
you guys came to the show first thought
they were good shows man and the people
great the club was great the food was
great I do it once a year
yeah and I don't leave the [ __ ]
cocina yeah and that's kind of out there
that's on the way yeah yeah it was so
crazy like I had this weird thing
happened to me this weekend it was just
weird how people act them women act and
now like this girl tried to keep luring
me out like casino I should leave Lea
she had no idea who she was up against
do you know like I'm just not like they
don't people really don't [ __ ] get me
like they think like I'm [ __ ] around
do you think that's maybe why she like
was so insistent because like probably
no one ever says no and like nothing
even heard it couldn't convince Joey
Diaz to leave the challenge the
challenge shampoos show dressed up when
she came in she said I can't wait that
you take me out around the town and I'm
looking at her finger she don't know
she's getting me [ __ ] grab an avocado
salad she's getting tossed I love it
that much as she tried like she started
calling me early she's a dear friend
love but I even told like a month it
wasn't gonna happen I did the opposite
Joey I can't do it I never party anymore
cuz I got a wife I got a two and a half
year old this weekend I was a monster I
don't know I think I've had a lot of
stress lately in my life my mom was sick
I got Bell's palsy like half my face
paralyzed and it was a tough month I
went down to San Diego love the city I
love to surf my opener was a buddy of
mine Joe pray know we it was just like I
got to the club and it was like I felt
like I was in college again like I gotta
get a drink cause I yeah and I was they
stood up the sushi place of course yeah
yeah and I went gosh I went and got I
went and got to Oh suit wait no sushi we
went to see Chinese and sushi okra right
across I think though or they have at
least something a little something to
the burrito place no I got taken a fish
places best [ __ ] fish I've had and so
long and a pizza I was doing shots of
tequila like so now like I'll do
two drinks a night and when I was young
I could drink a shitload it was like I
was young no hangovers I was going I
wasn't taking over home I was taking
golf carts home like guys driving golf
guy be like I'll pay you 20 bucks drive
me up there jump in their golf cart and
just you know eating Pete's out of the
back of it it was like I was in college
and there were there were a lot of girls
around but you know like there were
girlfriends a mine and like everybody
else does having a good time but I'm
like you know I'm not going there but it
was like I missed this for I didn't like
when I got married I was like I'm over
all that [ __ ] but I think for the past
like three to four years five years I've
kind of pushed that out of my life
completely so it was like hey this is
fun again this is fun
like I slept in my clothes both nights
kept my contacts in I just don't like
leaving I just don't like driving all
around Vegas that's I don't like I hate
that so like that's why when I go to the
South Point I plan it even before I get
that no exact time I'm leaving one time
to do and I'm a junkie I go to Mandalay
Bay
I call him in the corner of 12 the cars
that 10 after you know and I go back to
the hotel and I go to the gym or I
[ __ ] do you gambled on me I won this
week I played poker on the computer when
I hit him but I was telling me you know
two weeks ago I was in Long Island and
like some kid kept bugging me man I can
I buy you drinks all that drink I gotta
be a 4 o'clock car it's 120 mm I don't
drink anyway I said thank you I'm gonna
to the barn I gotta [ __ ] water
if this kid didn't ask me 20 times if he
could buy me a drink and I felt bad for
the kid cuz he finally walked away upset
but it's like once the aspect there you
know
get the [ __ ] out of my face it's not
gonna get a little better for you you
know you know what I do everyone till
I'm gonna tell you no it's [ __ ] no I
got like this I go can I buy you a drink
and then that's my way of getting out of
having to drink the alcohol be like then
like come on let me buy you a drink
when they're insistent no but these guys
yeah then a couple drinks of them
this girl was funny because she came she
goes well I'm just gonna
to show my I kept telling you you should
just wait till I get a leak I see if it
if she would've told me she was at the
Mirage I'm like I'll see you in 10
minutes
[ __ ] you you ain't gonna get me out turn
your phone on silent and it was funny
because she came to the show and I stole
my said she what do we do after she does
have friends at the Bellagio he's hit me
with all these names of places normally
listen this ain't looking good for you
right that's that's tough though to do
that but she why wasn't sexual I know
what she knows I'm married
yeah well I'm saying just like no run
around in Vegas is no yeah [ __ ] you I'm
not getting no [ __ ] old but du Boga
du Bois so I did it single no no no
leaving single I don't want to [ __ ]
leave yeah I did that [ __ ] one time
we're growing I didn't get back till
4:00 in the morning this [ __ ] lines
everywhere for a cab I moved this
traffic [ __ ] you know Friday she waited
for me till 1:00 in the morning she
finally cracked that one she'd almost
call when I got up there was a call from
let's go adventure got a weasel why
would they do that [ __ ] of a call around
to this and the corner answer that my
kind of bag of stars I could choke the
[ __ ] bellman
I'm gonna go to a weed store with you in
Vegas how many shows did you up there -
one on Friday you onstage at nine oh
you're so low you just want to be left
the [ __ ] alone
you know what your fate is you take some
pictures you do people hugs you go you
get a little clam chowder and you go
upstairs and thought that I hold on I
don't want to have a drink I don't want
to you know sailing all the time
I'm there to take pictures I'll sign
your [ __ ] I'll take the pictures we'll
talk but once it's time to go we got to
wrap it up and go you ain't gonna get me
at no [ __ ] club yeah never [ __ ] with
me jump and done then listen minutes no
it's not what I meant it I find peace
going up for that room I take a shower I
put my shorts on I go to the
refrigerator I take a [ __ ] apple
juice I like the head apple juice
waiting for Uncle Joe it's a little
Canada the treetops yeah yeah that's it
that's just I've I've probably been to
Vegas now you know 30 times I've only
think I've had one really fun night in
Vegas and I've fun a lot it's not like
I'm the boring like I'm not like this
guy that complains
it was just I did it it was I think it
was my it was uh my kind of fake
bachelor party where I invited fans of
the show that [ __ ] heads came out and we
all went to the hustler club because
they kind of sponsored my show a bit and
we acted like [ __ ] idiots and drank
and smoked and ended up and strip other
strip clubs till till the Sun came up
and that was the only time I've ever
gone hey that's a [ __ ] fun night
every other time it's just like well
I've had good nights and make another
had good night I had a good fun I had a
good time Friday night and Saturday and
I believe in that and a really good
[ __ ] time I check a few beers I want
a couple yard sticks I don't have to
leave the building
yeah I have to do deck doctor not that I
go straight to my room no it's just it's
the way I'm gonna can I'm gonna st.
Louis again all these people hit me at
listen you believe what you want to
believe no don't there's a guy that sent
me like this [ __ ] friend would quit
you know listen if you don't let me [ __ ]
with you I'm go [ __ ] if you don't let me
but if you're gonna be that stupid I'm
gonna [ __ ] with you there's a guy who
actually believed I was in the cinema
box of stars for the last five months
some guy in Iowa
has been hitting me you know that
messenger account that hidden account
you have on Facebook right and you click
on bonuses you get 2,000 messages yeah
and you click on put you feel horrible
these people think you hate them I am
and you find all these hidden messages
and [ __ ] it's creepy P so funny you talk
about that I [ __ ] creepiest thing it
only shows up every once in every once
in a while yeah
and you know I had a message on my hey
man or won't you shoot me over a box of
stars I would be your fan for life sure
why not and then he would hit back
really you would do that
my sure why not and he would go okay can
you also send me a shirt and a cup and
he asked for like 20 things I mean
absolutely the address he sent me there
all the explanations how to send it I
kept telling them yeah yeah yeah it's on
its way
finally the other things like I never
got the package you're [ __ ] did you
really send and I'm like are you [ __ ]
crazy
oh did you really believe I was this in
your bag it's not even know you you dumb
[ __ ] oh my I just fall off a [ __ ]
banana boat my goood send somebody a
[ __ ] package which stars in it
can you imagine two days there in the
fbi's now [ __ ] I go for them good for
them tell them yeah whatever you want I
be waiting for you I think if you're
that dumb if you're that dumb to say
that to me on Twitter then I got a play
with you I'm gonna treat you like the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that yeah you don't think
the FBI could be the on there like truck
there's a [ __ ] oscillate sure yeah
just keep telling me and then set up a
time and at me tell him you gonna meet
him in [ __ ] Vegas by the fountain at
midnight good luck I did that when the
internet first came out when it first
came out like we're talking like
nineteen this have been like 1990
around 1990 Maya my friend and I would
go in the lesbian chat line and troll
dudes and cuz we it was girl and you
knew it was just dude it was Ron so we'd
go on his guy as women we pretend we're
women to meet other women and then you'd
have dudes come into the room and talk
to the girls like the only place you
could get like
get weird on the internet was it so we
would troll these dudes and this is like
on a ll like you know you chat on I
think it might have been like pre that
or whatever but we would just say like
alright I'll meet you at this bar I'm
I'm gonna be by the jukebox and I'd say
things like I need you to wear a blue
hat I want you to put it on backwards so
I know who you know this is pretty cell
phones like I want you to put your hat
on backwards they know is 1994
this is 94 it was yeah and they'd go put
your hat on backwards and play this song
you know so I know who you are just send
these if it's nice isn't him the truck
stops and all kinda [ __ ] I met my friend
and I like as we got older right
we are trolls when we were like you know
like little kids like we were [ __ ]
with guys and like guys trying to like
pick up these like dirty lesbians they
thought we're gonna [ __ ] them and I'm
waiting on the Garden State Parkway
stop thinking they're getting a [ __ ]
I feel bad about it now but ish listen
if somebody's would be that stupid they
deserve what they got coming so I mean
you cannot go on one of those things and
really feel safe like I would feel well
you're a catfish sable I would [ __ ]
feel safe and know those situations what
what situation any of those situations
like going on a chitchat line and talk
to a broad that I don't [ __ ] see you
I like that you know whenever somebody
attacks me I'm like Twitter like on a
message like you get those wants the law
so he just tries to [ __ ] with your head
yeah I got it today out of the blue
I didn't haven't had it in a while and
it's like every three [ __ ] weeks but
they come together and like a wave and
I'm like did I go to that Twitter you
could tell that something right yeah oh
oh my go was the hallways yeah so that's
it's just I don't know
when when it comes in a wave like that
cuz I never like you know I'm not being
on Twitter or anything when I get and I
get I used to when I used to work with
Jim Jefferies I used to get so much hate
mail all day long like hundreds like
hundreds I was like and people like oh
you're you know your shows growing
skinny poppy I'm like I can't handle
this I was like I can't handle
they hate it's like killing me and then
so I don't get it much anymore and then
it'll come in a little wave and all I
figure is I must have been on TV last
night like I some a rerun of something I
did and they were just a bunch of dudes
sitting around going [ __ ] this guy like
like they hated me so much that they
were like sometimes one person has
multiple accounts it's funny because you
can go and I go to their page and they
all retweet each other like of the same
thing at the same time oh yeah this guy
just has like 18 accounts he's having
fun by himself I don't care about it
anymore cuz I I'm starting to totally
realize that but the people that do that
[ __ ] are just [ __ ] weird something's
wrong with them I can't imagine trolling
anyone other than Trump Facebook this is
where I get believing that Facebook I
get to wear this [ __ ] thing I'd the
last one I got was about eight days ago
a little chubby little blonde chick
about my age from my home town hit me
with a message if I knew somebody if I
grew up with a certain person I did grow
up with that person fuzzy is ya know ya
back and forth
very vague questions cuz I'll give you a
vague answer and I'll throw you
completely you said no I would never
think the thing that I wouldn't either
no I neither know you don't know nobody
nobody you don't know that person I wish
I would [ __ ] picture there that's a
guy that could be a guy ya lookin for
somethin did you grow up with him that
could be a public will he call those
people like a public of time people that
spy on people
oh all the P private investing I could
be a private investigator that's looking
at Lee for his divorce his wife hire
them and he's [ __ ] hittin you up is
Lee asking you're gonna go there [ __ ]
this weekend you know just that you
never know yeah why give me why it's
like those [ __ ] that answer
phone hi this is Tim McMillan I got
catfished once like oh you never open up
with your name I don't I gave too much
information
Nevin I don't know if it was a girl or a
guy I forget the whole situation but
they played me pretty hard it was a
weird thing I was trying to get a hold
of a girl and I sent her a message a
text message and apparently she had
gotten rid of her phone and someone had
the new phone and like someone had her
number and so this this person just
started playing me and they start
playing me really hard and it got like
really weird they told him they'd cancer
and all this stuff they knew I surfed
yeah I bought you a gift I'm gonna send
you a surfboard and all this stuff and
and I thought it was her the girl that I
knew the whole time and I'm like why is
this going on and and then I took it to
her friend I'm like why is she doing
this to me she's [ __ ] weird why is
this going on and she's like that's not
her number
I'm like what she's like she changed
numbers no it's [ __ ] weird this they
had something on 20/20 about the
basketball player the white guy from the
Denver Nuggets Birdman the white dude
that has all the tattoos yeah Birdman
about he was having a long business
relationship with a girl
that was set up by a girl and Alaska a
little [ __ ] girl in Alaska that's
all she does that's all she does that
football player for the Chargers had
that happen in college Notre Dame yeah
yeah and then I had kind of a funny one
I help people start podcasts sometimes
and I got one back like two or three
times and he they told me they were like
the third-base coach of the white shot
of the White Sox like a former player
and they said his name called love to
help and like two or three lay like [ __ ]
you all hey you talk and they that was
hot that was there in that they were
like the third-base coach of the White
Sox oh I forgot about this one we had a
girl that was a big fan of talking [ __ ]
when Jim and I were doing it and she
told us she had cancer that's been wants
to smell time we used to call her cancer
girl that was our joke name for we
called her cancer girl and we used to
wheezed it for a donation you could come
to the
and we told her you know what you can
come for free you come out here we'll
have you plop a but we said we'll even
pay for your flight you know because she
said she was telling us it was like
terminal and she loved the show and
everything and she was like hardcore
like she did crazy [ __ ] and you know
she's like I might just she was like
writing no she's I might not take my
treatment cuz I just want to die I don't
want to go through I've already been
through chemo once like a really really
in-depth story so she we said we'll fly
you out here she said I can't fly the
doctor Sam too sick to fly so I kind of
leave it at that sorry we'd love to have
you Jim used to do Jim Jefferies he was
like don't die you know like see a
cancer girl you know like he just gave
her a hard time so I'm doing a show in
Florida in Marco Island you've probably
done that No
so I'm doing the Marco Island gig and
this comedian I'm not gonna say his name
on here you guys probably know him he
said hey I'm flying down to Atlanta he
just told me he said can I come down and
I'll Drive down can I do a guest spot on
your show I said yeah no problem he I
said why are you gonna be down there he
was I'm flying into Atlanta and I'm
picking up cancer girl and I'm taking
her to I'm taking her to a concert and
then I'm gonna drive her down to see
your show because since she can't fly
out here so I'm gonna drive her and he
flew like I flew into Atlanta drove
somewhere really far picked her up and
then drove her down to like Naples the
south of [ __ ] Tampa so he shows up he
doesn't guest spot and everything she
hangs out she was kind of [ __ ] like
off the rails
she wrote graffiti on the wall in the
bathroom so it was really a girl though
it was a girl okay
it was a girl he hooks up with her or
whatever happens then we find out he's
hooking up with her we find out that our
intern has been webcam jerking off with
her then we find out she doesn't have
cancer
she lied to us that she had cancer and
did all that then she tells you open mic
or not the only the comedian that
brought her the truth that she could but
he got her pregnant
he's a woman he's a [ __ ] sociopath
like that's why you avoid people like
not have
to be very careful in today's [ __ ]
Candice thing with me was [ __ ] crazy
because I watched it all right no I
don't know what you're talking about
okay if you sent me something else I
noted that and then she asked me if I
did Tommy and they probably some North
Bergen and I said yeah obviously you
know that you asked me about that guy
and then that was it I left I come back
on this three messages and what who I
thought was her in a bikini Anna I'm
looking at this little chubby girl boom
like she send this picture her over the
[ __ ] bar with the tape what to attend
when they weather the whole thing that
would be like a bikini I would like this
one piece I want people it's really not
a bikini the Borat
yeah whatever the [ __ ] it is Oh gotcha
she sends me one of those and then it's
something else doing splits so I'm like
picture your [ __ ] don't bother don't
bother cuz you only get my attention
just send please don't get that it ever
anymore no no I don't get it either but
if you want to get my attention send me
a picture of your monkey but I really
that thing else everything else gets a
thumbs up I don't even look at it I
don't I don't give a [ __ ] I know I used
to get some of that before us married
yeah because they tell people you're
married like me well old dogs would you
send a picture of your dick to a 70 year
old lady Manny
no you wouldn't now you [ __ ] wouldn't
alright it's the same thing who I don't
even want pictures of [ __ ] my point was
that you're not gonna get my attention
unless you send me a picture your [ __ ]
like that I'm fired or blowing a roman
candle or something I don't want to see
you in a [ __ ] bikini so I leave it at
that
like I didn't even answer back which
probably drove her crazy you know so
about a week later and then I go and I
plug the computer on in Vegas Saturday
morning and I'm up early I'm like seven
I'm waiting for [ __ ] room service and
oh really
let's start looking through it and I saw
she sent me another message like click
she sent me pictures of a chubby
daughter I'm looking like she's lovely
like yeah like bow people are [ __ ]
[ __ ] man so you never know like
seductress you know we're very lucky we
have Bobby Shannon crystal and Bob
Lingus and [ __ ] the Armenian you know
[ __ ] what's his name he brings me
bread Oh Burgie we're very lucky that we
do you guys ever thought of that too
everyone probably brings you drugs no no
no we have people on the road in certain
cities that show up bring me something
to kill we liquid acid the paper acid
it's always something to kill we've long
he said no no they don't bring me drugs
they bring me stuff to kill me have you
guys had shane moss on here Seamus
Seamus a really good dude really funny
comedian too my god from Minneapolis and
he does the same black dude no no not
that shame that's Randy Moss though
that's tough though Randy Moss is a wide
receiver
Shane Moss is a white dude and or any he
does a whole show now a comedy show on
psychedelics and he just loves them he's
done DMT like 60 times yeah I don't want
that [ __ ] bullet to go people cover
the talk gonna be [ __ ] you know he's
great he's really smart and he's really
into it great white looks really into it
across from these picking these [ __ ]
deputies whatever you've never done DMT
no really just to acid and join the real
one stop [ __ ] around with baby [ __ ]
doesn't it for 60 seconds and cry and go
on a corner and tell people my
insecurities I'll give you a listen
we'll do it drop and I [ __ ] there to
shake you you'll hang out and Oakland
Joey you'll be fine I'll go
no more DMT I will take you to what side
you need to stay a little container
right there oh there that's what that is
that's what that is
oh god that's my ice cube right there so
you take the DMT I'll never do that kid
stuff sorry I like a big kick but I'm
not I'm amazed that more people don't
dose people like people don't get I know
I know but it it'd be so easy to get
away with no one know what's something
that you don't want those people no no
I'm saying I've been drugged once in my
life yeah that's right because you were
watching your [ __ ] glass that's
exactly what happened when what's your
[ __ ] glass so this is but it was a
good good good situation I think Joey
doesn't know sight like dude Joey
convinces the people to dose them selves
almost like Paulie no well here's the
thing man me [ __ ] around with him you
know his level I know that he had a it
was time for him to push it like in the
beginning I was giving him big packages
and telling him there were small
packages so I was playing with his mind
he thought he was doing 35 milligrams me
what I was doing 100 and going Lions
just killing me cuz it's a strong cookie
but whatever he thought he was even he
was really the double because it's ones
they don't I was lifting and not trying
lifting his resistance without him
knowing
have you always had a friend like this
that was like your guy that you got peer
pressured and oh my god all my friends
knew when you were around me if I had
blow we had to do it yeah
if I got but I didn't you know when you
start held I started getting high on
weed when I was about 12 13 playing
basketball I was really a jock but the
jocks in those days got high yeah it
wasn't like jocks not walking oh we
gotta [ __ ] thought alright we've
robbed beer trucks and we did all that
type of [ __ ]
but the it was 78 when I really started
[ __ ] around 79 and the other drug was
acid
I was bladder windowpane that all acid
was everywhere there was five bucks four
bucks three bucks two bucks you know you
had nickel bags of marijuana nickel bag
so you got seven joints for five hours I
couldn't do acid I don't know and then
you had angel dust you could smoke it
but what's the feeling from angel dust
like the world is crashing and you just
[ __ ] float like that was weird like
every drug I did okay like I did the
[ __ ] weed just because I liked it I
liked top music sound it with weed
that's where I really last yeah for weed
the beginning because I like the music
and then I don't know why I can't tell
you what made me do acid as much as I
hated all that [ __ ] I didn't really know
there was no internet in those days you
had no you couldn't WebMD
yeah you just talked to different people
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know you know
you're [ __ ] there was no Yelp right
you know there's no Yelp you didn't
believe nobody they told me I got three
friends right yes you do that [ __ ] yeah
we have a good time beautiful should I
do it [ __ ] yeah it's gonna change your
life okay done that's it
there's no thinking there's no what you
get I don't give a [ __ ] what you want to
do as well an acid tonight that's when
people talk about parenting it's like
yeah it's all about who your kids
hanging out and you know was I always
had somebody growing up by two or three
dudes that we got down with
we all have the same tolerance but so
did you
peer pressure them like you do know him
peer pressure him because he wouldn't do
anything if he doesn't do this these two
nights this is it oh really
he'll sit home what color was the purple
college is purple and [ __ ] anything
bad he'll watch and they'll cook blue
apron oh and don't [ __ ] stay in and
do you really put her apron yeah it's so
good and he [ __ ] the watches you know
this is it this is it does he have a
girl diva game he is a living girl she's
not only at least he's a savage ish I've
always been kind of uh my kind of I've
always been really like a nerdy and like
just boring yeah baby you said huafei
yes sure sure whatever you want I used
to I used to not understand people are
nerdy and boy it I couldn't understand
how it happened and now that I'm kind of
married I'm kind of nerdy and boring
myself and I'm happy with it I'm like
although they were happy with it their
whole life I always just assumed they
were like misra I'm like why would you
want to be like that and now that I am
like that I'm like I get it I want to go
home and just sit well my wife part of
me part of me doesn't want part of me is
like oh maybe I should have party but
then literally 97% of the people I talk
to about her like oh you didn't miss
anything like in reality look you know I
had some eyes and great [ __ ] times I
wouldn't want to do it now but I mean I
did this weekend but it was like I just
can't handle it like I did and I and I
regret I had lots of regrets of like
throwing away years of my life for just
partying like you probably educated
yourself and I went to an art school so
not really okay
you know Lee is you see you know I'm 54
now I see the generations and I see the
difference isn't it Jenna
I really do I really do I don't name
them yeah I don't know what the ex
generation is [ __ ] Pepsi generation
what a millennial is I don't know that
[ __ ] I'm gonna have four [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what I [ __ ] know and half of
them behalf of [ __ ]
you know POTUS for these new people get
body eyes from weed I never heard this
[ __ ] but that's what we're dealing with
today people who say POTUS 92,000
presence also not even all the
components all right you know everybody
with this you go to a weave store and
then destroyed the we do this tree with
their [ __ ] it's [ __ ] with the
body highs and no now there's a new
thing micro dosing like we don't really
get high we micro dose let me let me put
my dick in your mouth now while we have
the chance before somebody [ __ ] shoot
you well go on into some scary times at
these [ __ ] type of beep you know my
girls joy oh yeah all the time
we doesn't like wrote those mm you macro
you macro dose we macro Dulles we broke
the [ __ ] a bank of a macro micro
gives a [ __ ] but it's just amazing where
we're going house off we'd be coming it
[ __ ] tears me up that people micro
dose when they tell you now just upset
to you at night by yourself
oh well I'm sitting there drivers I'm
smoking a big [ __ ] bong and I hear
people telling me they micro dose this
morning after their morning yoga session
I don't want to sit there and go what
the [ __ ] is this any what's this boy
you're doing what is the name of this
door I'm going it's called the bingo all
the way and we're taking that bingo bus
I bought a bus for about 10 grand did a
Kickstarter and we put about 65 grand
into the bus now that was what the cakes
are now it's up to like ninety-five
grand and it's I could probably sell the
bus for about two grand maybe three if
anyone wants to buy it
cuz it's just [ __ ] digging every day
it's something else
every day I gotta like fix the ID rats
in it the chewed all the wiring ten
thousand dollars a wire and just
everything but I finally said well you
know I told the fans I was going to
around the country so we're leaving on
the 19th of 19th of July and we're going
this is a tour we're going to San Jose
that night Eugene Oregon nine hours
later the next night Seattle the next
night then we go over to Spokane down to
Boise Salt Lake City we're going to
Denver Lincoln Nebraska st. Paul Chicago
Illinois Madison Wisconsin Iowa City
Dubuque and then we're talking about
stopping in Vegas on the way back for
this weed thing but it's it's [ __ ]
and it's me it's not like you know when
guys got on a tour bus it's nice and
they got Bette and still that's tough
this is a shitty hold school bus how
many guys on the bus so we're gonna have
four total and it's it's a it's all nice
inside like I you know I'm I saw the big
screen TV yeah yeah it's really
beautiful inside and but one of my
cameraman my cameraman guy said I got
like an audio guide and one of them does
merchants and then I got a comedian that
comes with me and open my [ __ ] we all
take turns I'll even be doing it I'm a
soldier on this thing like I'm not the
leader like that we're all in this
together one of my [ __ ] my cameraman
today sends me a contract I want this I
want this I want this I want that and I
went I want a new cameraman he's like
making all these demands I go I'm with a
big agency when I go to a club there's
like three lines in my contract your
contract - come on talk with me like
five pages so we're gonna have a good
time though we have tailgate parties at
the bus so we just opened we got a keg
on the bus we tequila we drink for the
party smoke on the bus everything and do
the show stand-up show and then
everybody comes out to the bus
afterwards tailgate and we do a live
podcast I was the twenty days
days I'm leaving my wife and kid for 20
days to ride around this like it's
smaller than this room Joey
I like the tool I hate the predicament
everybody busts that there's a blow-up
in dubuque [ __ ] kid I know
everybody's making better everybody's
gonna wanna bring a bet but [ __ ] you
better have Plan B just in case you got
some short dates to him between [ __ ]
yeah you have some short times there I'm
jeanna Oregon if you tell me you had
rats god knows what by the ways in that
[ __ ] doesn't have AC no no but listen
listen listen I've been working on AC
all week and every single fan has like
an opinion on AC and we were like do we
do batteries do we do generators do we
get an alternator do we the people are
going you're gonna put dry ice in a
bucket and blow a fake they're giving us
every kind of way and I'm just like so I
I think we've narrowed it down we're
gonna have AC by the time we go but how
we have it is a [ __ ] nightmare I
would do it through a generator and like
a dry of a swamp
yeah whatever swung cooler that's what I
think we're doing it to that's only way
I can see it and then every stop
recharged to generate in generally last
10 hours
yes that's it you stop but every time
you stop you charge it yeah while you're
eating you charge yourself sir
these people that my cell phone's dead
what the [ __ ] did you do when you were
home it's gonna be ugly
take a shower when you come back the
thing is ready the same thing with that
[ __ ] thing you plug in the bus you go
eat that subway whatever the [ __ ] you
gonna do cuz there ain't no morons on
this day no no there ain't no Morton's
on this little your love give you get a
napkin and [ __ ] this is like one of
those tours they take the signal and
pound man on you ever see when they put
him in the back of the u-haul and they
take him across the country to fat [ __ ]
and every three hours he's got to stop
he's back there stop stop
that's I feel like that's what I've done
I've created this tour that's like
[ __ ] okay every was acute you have to
do it and I was like why don't they're
like you built the bus and it's funny
we're going to Dubuque Iowa where a
[ __ ] Field of Dreams it's my friend
cuz you know what's a club in the buccal
I'm doing the cute casino
that was there a club in there I think
you're thinking um the Quad Cities right
what club was in there I was called um
penguins hang with penguins now they
have a club on this ship they do now I
don't know they had the club downtown
I forget I used to open for a towel I
opened for a tell there and uh we had a
[ __ ] good week there because they
used to have like though Thursday Friday
at the club and then Saturday you went
to his ship and then that ship had a
comedy club in it and it was like a
funny bone something the chick that ran
that Club know more about comedy nan yes
man where is she I don't know I'll tell
you this up I hope my god yeah I hooked
up with a waitress there me too and we
had sex and never thought anything of it
again you know see ya good seeing ya and
someone new like one of my friends knew
and told jim Florentine is a good friend
of mine told him and I called Jim or
something and he or he just come back
from there and he said uh I said hey I
was the gig and he goes I go did you see
so-and-so and he goes all you mean the
pregnant girl and I go what he is the
pregnant waitress you know she's like
and he knew how long ago I was there
he's like she's like six months pregnant
you talking about that girl and I'm like
I forget her name Carly or something
Carly he's like yeah Carly the pregnant
girl I said [ __ ] it
wait you had to be [ __ ] kidding me
and he's like oh yeah she said she was
talking about her you know she I said
did she have a boyfriend her husband
Ernie no no no I think some comic
knocked her up and I'm like
[ __ ] and I just lost my [ __ ] I mean it I
was panicking so hard and you guys yeah
you're all [ __ ] gullible one you fell
for this [ __ ] and he just got me so
[ __ ] good so good
I fell for I was convinced for like you
know I was like aw [ __ ] I got it I got a
kid in Quad Cities Illinois I had a
weird experience I did MADtv maybe that
maybe something else I do not know but
whatever I did this waitress saw this is
the way this [ __ ] thing like that
happens here on the road
it's a Saturday night Sunday they drive
you get on the [ __ ] plane you come
home Saturday night she comes up to me
introduce ourselves and says can I take
you somewhere after here I want to
introduce you to my biggest fan in the
[ __ ] world on those days I was doing
powder yeah so you'd go out if this
happened I didn't say that
at first I go let me see how what
happens after the show and she goes
trust me you don't want to go to this
thing so I mean every 10 minutes when I
see you and she goes get ready they have
a good time
I'm like what the [ __ ] is this girl talk
second show that's the [ __ ] night
where I'm sitting there I don't know how
many people in the audience and the
manager comes to me she goes I by the
way the second show rod white and Jeff
Foxworthy alone the other guy I do only
guest said Wow like are you [ __ ]
crazy
are you [ __ ] I'm not following this
anime like I'm not [ __ ] following
those savages and they came in and it
was great I started drinking [ __ ]
doers and I started hanging out I smoked
enjoy so afterward the girl came over
she goes what are you gonna do I know
I'm gonna go with them and she grabbed
my arms listen to me I'm gonna take you
there might be some powder whereas when
we get there but trust me I thought
there was a catch because those type of
girls always have a boyfriend yeah they
always datin the dirtiest [ __ ]
dumbest waiter in the [ __ ] place
sure enough to show and she's like you
know who else is gone like just being
you
I think I had a little token of my
pocket like I copped a little something
from one of the [ __ ] casino do is I
suppose Spanish casino through and I
worked in rather where we hear the
Polly's I give me five minutes
we're like cousin there really is so
much yeah so we get in the [ __ ] car
we try about 20 minutes real cute girl
you know I mean I'm sitting oh what the
[ __ ] is going on
I gotta be 40 at the time during you
know you know just chicks maybe 26 and
she started as a strip club
yeah and I go what are we doing here she
goes
your biggest fan and works here can I
take anything ever [ __ ] fans yeah I
know three people I thought I would see
I should probably see thee yeah what the
[ __ ] she talking she takes me when she
takes my hand and she just wanna follow
me she takes me to one little back rooms
yeah we're strippers take and she'll sit
right here I'm thinking I'm getting shot
I'm like this is a hit this is a [ __ ]
head I don't have a weapon on me
I got nothing so I wasn't real quick you
got a bottle of [ __ ] be it and I'm
like I'm gonna sit here and wait till
whatever happens happens I'm Hanuman it
was a [ __ ] yeah yeah I know who
[ __ ] isn't [ __ ] the point i right
that's right why is a [ __ ] beautiful
girl with red hair and a great body
asking me to come to a strip club with
her and now she leaves me in this
[ __ ] private room by myself in the
middle of all this anxiety banned the
[ __ ] door opens up that waitress was
in a [ __ ] bikini with no top line Oh
she was claimed over and gave me a lap
dance
it was [ __ ] I couldn't believe it it
was just me and her in this room I go
how do you do this she goes I working
part-time Oh
bringing his a surprise I was like Oh
what the [ __ ]
but you know I dropped her I dropped
I gather I got a little monkey into
troubled I met the girl the girl who
catfished me well who I thought
catfished me uh and it was someone else
she used to be a girl that hung out she
was like a hanger out her at the improv
and I thought she was pretty hot
one night she hung around a lot so they
love comics one night I was at the bar I
was drinking with them and she came home
with me and I had sex with her and a lot
of comics saw me leave with her and I
get a text from I think if Ryan stout
did it to me you know right Ryan sends
me a text and it's just a link you guys
check this out it's the girl I'm with
you know in just a hardcore porno just I
had no idea and she was just getting
like it was like called like coeds need
cash and she's just getting like [ __ ]
by like just right after beds eggs for
there and I'm like oh but you let me
walk out of there without like they all
knew all the comics were like and no one
said anything and they just let me go
home with this chick and I know people
are listening right now and go what's
the big day I probably still would have
gone home if she said you know I do porn
but it's just like you meet this chicken
you think she's one thing and then you
see her sucking this giant black [ __ ]
and I was making out with him so what's
the name of your tour these people get
to go the bingo all the way tour
it's at Eddie IFFT calm IFFT and it's
starting July 19th and it ends like
August 4th or 5th and it's every night
and are my new podcast comes out
tomorrow bring it I like tunes right the
iTunes it's called the Bingle show be
ing le [ __ ] bingo bingo bingo
what's up with you over there Lisa Ann
see you made it another podcast you were
scared I'm scared I'm not doing nothing
you're doing it nothing's happening to
your tall mental these [ __ ] mental
midgets you're savage look here you're a
Jewish type of death anyway speaking of
Jewish tanks and [ __ ] that
don't forget for all your supplements go
to Han it alikom right now alpha brain
listen you tried you don't like it get a
hundred percent money-back guarantee
how's that for you gonna calm right now
and press in church bad get 10% off that
[ __ ] you understand me number
two do me a favor listen and I'm
responsible for this for dressing like a
[ __ ] war two down because you know
for years I dress nice but then I said
what the [ __ ] I'm too old to lie to
people and now I'm too old to dress like
I'm [ __ ] dressing so I'm thinking of
making the move over here too because
look looking good doesn't need to cost
you a fortune all right five four Club
is revolutionizing the way men shop come
on take that off brother stop with the
[ __ ] phone
each months they send you a curated box
of two to three items that are
hand-picked to match the current season
in your style they've been helping men
in fashion for over 15 years and shipped
over on a thousand men every month they
know what they're doing so if you don't
that's okay five for club will help you
build your wardrobe one month at a time
why because when you look good you smell
good you feel good it's a fact of life
we're gonna get your hundred twenty
hours worth of clothes for sixty dollars
a month you can pause or cancel anytime
there's no commitment and there's a five
for club member you also receive 50% off
items in their online shop and access to
exclusive Members Only items free
shipping and size exchanges here's where
the party starts you ready go to five
for club.com right now and enter promo
code Joey and they're gonna give you 50%
off your first month package plus a free
pair of sunglasses who's better than you
uncle Joey nobody that's 50% off your
first package at 5-4 Club spelled fi ve
fo you are club.com
promo code Joey five four club.com promo
code Joey go out there dressed like a
[ __ ] Savage understand
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with
number two let me explain something to
you do you know that depending on where
you got your mortgage you can save
twenty thousand dollars or more did you
know that but 80 percent of people who
only get one mortgage or for like I did
and if you just go to your bank chances
are they rip you off that's why I didn't
take the loan from them Lending Tree
doesn't want that to happen here's the
thing the average Lending Tree customer
can save twenty thousand over the life
of their loan that's the average half of
their customers could save even more
whether you're looking for a new
mortgage refinance home equity loan
Lending Tree is the only place where you
get up to five real offers from
America's top lenders and you can
compare side-by-side for free and guess
what it only takes three minutes it's
like shopping for flights online your
only shopping for the best mortgage
offers for you rates always go up and
down but regardless of what's happening
with the rates you can always get the
right offer for you with Lending Tree
calm are you sure you have the best deal
right now find out much more safe today
golden Lending Tree calm / Church that's
right go to and built listen take a
chance Columbus did
that's Lending Tree calm / church again
Lending Tree calm / Church I'm gonna
save you some money you're gonna be
happy with the new housing that saved
some money
Lending Tree LLC nmls 1 136 terms and
conditions apply but go to Lending Tree
coms last Church I want to thank my man
Eddie if thank you and stopping in
tonight you bad [ __ ] I want to
thank my manly sigh yeah
don't forget [ __ ] st. Louis get your
[ __ ] together
I'm slinging dick Thursday night helium
I'll be there Friday and Saturday too
but the party starts Thursday night and
then July 29th I'm telling you every
time they send me those [ __ ] numbers
there's less and less tickets don't [ __ ]
around the Borgata July 29th there you
have it I love you [ __ ] we'll
be back I'll let you know tomorrow right
stay black Eddie IFFT and EF dot-com my
man Lisa at have
great [ __ ] day stay black uncle Joey
loves you poor God I still does it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]